the name or the number was 81 and the
player right now is genius
eleven-year-old if this is true then
what that's very cool if this is an
eleven-year-old right now has a 2312
rating very cool or might these this
just be what a psychological game let's
run with this and see what see what
white is going to do in response to this
might be having c5 real soon um ok now
I'm going to take because I can well
actually not because I can but rather
because because of what I want to play
night to be four if given the
opportunity I took only after the bishop
moved so i saw that i'm not wasting time
so I'm not speeding up White's
development I want to get in night b4 to
d5 I also want my bishop on b7 I think a
move that maybe should have been played
there was 83 to keep my night out of or
my night from being able to pivot on the
b four square and also allowing for the
bishop to back up to a two and maybe
eventually redirect itself on this
diagonal so this is interesting we could
have I guess I'm content with no longer
having what content with no longer
having play against this pond right here
so this is interesting I'm going to go
with this see what the white side is
going to do here and if there's Bishop
takes Knight I actually have to come
back here I think everything's alright
i'll be able to develop finally
so let's go here I do have to be a
little bit cautious of this square
without a doubt in an ideal world I
would like to have the light square
Bishop soph the board a pair of nights
off the board and my night to be able to
sit right here on d5 rook c8 is my first
thought to have any second thoughts not
so sure let's go here there's not really
going to be a better square for it this
pond is unprotected I don't know if why
you could be exploiting that I guess
maybe some Queen may be coming here or
the night and that's so not so much I
could be playing a six in response to
both actually a queen here or night move
here so now what looking for some trades
and this is a typical thing to look into
if you are the side that what if you're
playing against the isolated pond look
forward to making exchanges it's going
to decrease the possibility of your
opponent coming through with some attack
and for a second I thought that after I
recapture what there was Bishop to a six
but there is this pin going on and if
Bishop recaptures I conveniently
recapture with my queen I use the word
convenient because I'm then fully
developed that's exactly what I would
like to have happen okay so this is
where we're at now there might be Bishop
takes Knight I think that might be best
but then again White is giving up the
bishop and in this end game I think I'm
going to be standing better so now there
he goes and there he will stay there's
no chasing this night away from d5 could
only ever be challenged with the night
and I think that is what my opponent is
looking forward to doing now I don't
want to allow for what what don't I want
to allow for I don't want the dark
square Bishop scum off the board I don't
want to get into a night versus night
end game okay yes the rooks too but
night versus night I would much rather
have like
a night versus bishop or something so I
think actually this move is a good idea
and it's basically saying you can't go
here just yet or you know actually well
maybe it could actually this move could
still be played Bishop d6 because of
back rank problems hmm interesting ok
still is playable this is a imaginary my
rook really really is not here to guard
this this square but now now it is
because I have a flight square I'm not
only hitting the bishop but I have this
if this move is going to be played a
bishop or night the rook is going to
have to capture first on that square so
now I think I improved my king position
I do have to be very cautious about this
night being able to pivot here I am okay
with giving up my bishop for night I
want to sneak my king around on d7
control all the entry points that these
rooks might have and I think I do one
better to actually come over here still
inching my king / King position King
position again and I think actually ah i
could have now threatening to win the
night actually oh no I'm not I'm winning
the bishop pawn push this is the mistake
that's it now that my king is here
watching over the square pawn push pawn
push again the bishop can't play here so
that was a mistake also with this pawn
push there was no night retreat so then
gets cooked now got the bishop and
there's nothing else to do right my
opponent is typing good game good game
back
uh
I'm asking my opponent right now if they
are listening to the stream and I'm also
asking if they are really 11 years old
curious anyhow well if you are 11 years
old actually don't feel like you have to
answer so anyhow very good game whether
or not you are 11 or not all the more
impressive if you are 11 so anyhow we
have and also keep at it very cool it's
it's great to see a young talent in the
game so ok pana Botvinnik attack that's
what we have here this is the exchange
caro-kann c4 is going to denote the pan
of Bob panic attack and as black you'll
want to be cautious about deploying the
knight to c6 because of potential
structural changes namely c5 and then
Bishop b5 bulbs where after Bishop takes
Knight having that resulting structure a
black pot on c6 and D 5 verses d4 and c5
is a bit well it's not good for black so
there's a reason for not running with
knight c6 in this position but rather
moves like Bishop e7 and castle now
during the game already made reference
to it instead of the bishops development
I think a3 is worth the closer look stop
the night from pivoting here and then if
you really want to deploy your Bishop to
f4 however know that when you play your
Bishop to f4 that you run the risk of
tempo gaining moves as occurred in the
game where once my night played to d5
I'm hitting the bishop and this is
something you could pretty much
anticipate me doing I do want to have a
night here and when it does play there
ok it's hitting the bishop so keep that
in mind I think a 383 right here is an
improvement Bishop out later Brooksie
one you could tuck the bishop back maybe
get to be one and again focus on this
diagonal
stuff i was saying during the game those
are my suggestions because i feel that
right now I'm just better the position
is simplified we are in an endgame
position this is no longer well it never
really turned out to be a positive thing
right now it's a negative having that
isolated pond I have control over the
blockade square so I guess when it gets
to this point what's the better move
then be four maybe white is now having
to already take into account this this
push of course so maybe f3 but no not
even f3 I wonder if like h3 is needed or
maybe the night playing here actually
that's not working because that that
ends up dropping this pond or does it
yeah pretty much drops that pond there's
this serious problems Mike like if
Knight c3 I could exchange a couple
times and there's some rook moves
pivoting on c4 coming over to a 4 and
this pun is not going to be saved this
Bishop is a bit out of play and it's all
as a result of this night just being
really well placed in the center so my
early suggestion is to test out 83 at
this point right as soon as I have the
ability to play to be for consider a 3
okay